each one of the rooms the characters
encounter in escape room has an intended
solution but if breadth of the wild has
taught me anything is that there's often
more than one possible solution for any
given puzzle and I don't think they
always found the intended path stick
around to the end of the video if you
want to hear the real solutions for
these rooms welcome back
see you things you missed and Happy New
Year 2019 I've got an exciting week
packed with content for you this week
and to kick it all off we're gonna be
covering some of the hidden details and
their meanings in the first horror movie
of the year
a stapler let's start with the beginning
of the movie
the opening shot pulls out from a
chessboard you're probably thinking that
this is a microcosm of the entire movie
being a chess match against the creators
of the game and these participants are
just trying to become the last piece
standing there's actually a little bit
more to it than that
when Zoey heads back to her dorm after
class there's a poster advertising a
chess group meeting at the college that
might be where she gets some of her
deductive reasoning skills because I
spotted a chess piece in her room but it
wasn't just any chess piece it was a
king and if you've ever played chess you
know that the king is the one piece that
must remain standing in order for the
game to continue so when Zoey faked her
death in the hospital themed room I knew
that we hadn't heard the last of her but
that's not the only clue left in the
opening scene the flash-forward of Ben's
final test there's also some Latin text
printed at the top of the wall near the
ceiling that says octa asked fabula
which roughly translates to the play is
over or the performance is over a clue
that the entire game was created for
entertainment which is explained once
Ben reaches the final room that's not
the only clue towards the game being in
an entertainment trial for the
super-rich we are first introduced to
Zoey at her college physics lecture her
professor brings up a phrase a watched
pot never boils
and explains that may actually be true
under the quantum Zeno effect in which
observation stops movement in atoms
Zoey's plan for getting out kind of
mirrors that effect she smashes every
camera in the room so she's no longer
being observed then passes out and waits
for the cleanup crew to come around so
she can take them out and escape
after that lecture she has a little chat
with her professor who tells her that
reducing variables won't change the
outcome at the time it's more of a
reference to her life choices of being
an introvert but you could also apply it
to the game and say she's doomed to
eventually lose no matter what's the
name of the company who runs the escape
room is - the logo of this company is
explained in the movie but its name is
not it goes back to ancient Greek
mythology - is the first king of Crete
who commanded that seven young boys and
seven young girls be sent into the
labyrinth a giant maze structure that
houses a Minotaur with the intention
that they would be eaten by the Minotaur
in other words the company being named -
should have been a huge red flag that
the seven contestants were not meant to
survive seven seems to be a recurring
number throughout the movie as well in
addition to the seven contestants when
you add in the guy introduced in the
game at the winners room there are seven
rooms and the clue in the second room is
a seven letter word
seven of course is considered a lucky
number and the winner of each game is
considered lucky to be alive when Zoey
and Ben meet up again after getting out
alive they get lunch together on st.
Patrick's Day which is often considered
to be a lucky day but let's get back to
when the contestants all meets Amanda
the redhead girl reads a newspaper
headline about five people being burned
alive I would theorize this is another
iteration of the game or a beta testing
of the game the waiting room turns out
to be the first trial room the giant
oven anyone who's played ocarina of time
should have figured out how those
weight-sensitive pedestals work but it
didn't click for them until it was
almost too late the obvious intended
solution was to fill the cups up with
water and place them on the switches
however they didn't have enough water
because Amanda drank some of it so they
ended up using some liquid that Ben had
in a flask they also could have had
someone pee in the last Cup or place
literally any heavy object in the room
on top of the cup but they were lucky
enough to have the flask on hand so they
moved on to the inside of the cabin
where they needed a seven letter word to
advance if you don't remember the word
was a Rudolph there were three clues in
the cabin and Ben was able to figure it
out only having found two the text that
said you'll go down in history which to
be honest should have been enough on its
own the other clue they saw was the
reindeer Mantle's again probably should
have been enough on there
but they didn't seem to notice that the
camera in this room is the only one in
the game with a blinking red recording
light which could have also tipped them
off as a clue pointing to Rudolph's
shining red nose after solving that
puzzle they move on to the ice level it
starts with them finding the jacket and
Zoe gets to wear it for a bit and she
discovers the compass with the text True
North is a lie this is actually the same
compass seen hanging from her mother's
pocket when she later has the flashback
to the plane crash that killed her
family and the brand of the compass is
Stanley London and London happens to be
the location that she buys plane tickets
to in order to infiltrate - at the end
of the movie meanwhile Mike gets
distracted by the husky dog which
matches the description of his old dog
that he told everyone about when they're
all still in the waiting room this leads
to him finding the fishing rod in the
tree the compass leads to the magnet and
the magnet goes on the bottom of the
fishing rod to help him find the ice box
which has the key this is where the
intended solution is a little bit
unclear I don't really buy that they're
supposed to use the warmth of their
hands to melt the ice I do have a theory
of them there's one object that's never
used the thermometer maybe they're
supposed to break open the thermometer
and spill out the mercury on the ice
block I looked it up and I guess mercury
is not flammable but in the presence of
water it can become explosive this is
assuming that they don't lose the
lighter which they do when Danny falls
through the ice if you're an expert on
chemistry let me know if that would
actually work because honestly I have no
idea they also could have potentially
started a fire using the branches from
the tree so there may have been more
than one solution there next room is the
upside-down eight ball room where the
song downtown plays over and over on
repeats everything they need to know to
solve this puzzle is in the lyrics if
they had only stopped to listen
[Music]
it's literally telling them stop and
listen to the music first
[Music]
in this case the sidewalk is the area on
the sides of the room where the floor
isn't falling away and the neon signs
are the color coded puzzles which
corresponds to the numbered balls on the
pool table is telling them that if they
study these signs they won't lose
[Music]
this line is a bit trickier but it's
basically telling them to go down but
since the rim is upside down they really
need to go up and that's where a man
defines the safe this just lets them
know that they have limited time to
solve the room
Amanda ends up hanging from the
telephone wire and the problems that
surround her are the bottomless pits on
each side of her I mean not bottomless
but you know what I mean she sits there
and hangs around and ends up paying the
price for it
[Music]
the other contestants literally offer
Amanda a helping hand when she's hanging
there but she doesn't take it this movie
is absolutely filled with other possible
clues so if you caught anything I didn't
notice in my video go ahead and let me
know in the comments new year new merch
that's right now you can get a my life
as a horror movie merch which looks like
this exclusively from the Seas world
merch store look how good this looks I'm
gonna get it and you should get it too
the link will be waiting for you in the
description remember to subscribe to
seize these worlds for new Horrors every
week bring that death Bell for
notifications and I'll see you in the
next one assuming we both survive
[Music]